welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
animation details that you might have
missed in the latest trailer for
Spider-Man across the spider-verse new
rock stars divided and conquered on this
one Jessica Clemens broke down all the
Spider-Man cameos and our Easter egg
breakdown Mt will break down the
Multiverse logic in another video but in
this video I'm just gonna focus with mad
intensity at the Fun details hidden in
the animation the character design the
world design the way characters move
because new Rockstar super fans might
know that I moved to San Francisco
because my wife works with Pixar
Animation and our dog Darla is named
after this human piranha and my favorite
kind of stuff in movies is when like you
know Lucas eyes dilate when he looks
into the sun it's not really a reference
to anything it's just an awesome easy to
miss Choice made by a talented team of
artists and these Sony spider-verse
movies are filled with goodies like that
so I'm just gonna break all of that down
so again in this video I'm not gonna
identify all the Spiderman Jess already
did that for us and in this video if I
point out an animation detail you don't
need to go tell Jess that she missed
ditching and miss it she was just
leaving it for me to find just like I'm
intentionally ignoring all the cameos
here so that she can find them see the
new Rockstar's co-star sharing the load
on this one and thank God because it
gives me a lot more time to dive into
this animation like right at the top the
O in the Sony glitches open to be a few
hexagonal Rings the interdimensional
portals that Miles and Gwen and
everybody else Glides through and as
usual the Columbia Pictures lady
glitches to a couple animated forms
looks like we get a Jughead Comics
version another one with shading lines
but back to my wife's mother is actually
an occupational therapist to the real
life woman who was the model for this
logo uh did I just violate some HIPAA
[ __ ] I hope not okay we stayed in on
this quiet moment between miles and his
mother Rio
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order now as before they animate miles
at 12 frames per second which is half of
the usual 24 frames in modern animation
all they have miles a more staggered
movement and to help each of his poses
stand out more forcing us and miles to
live in his Beats which for Miles means
he really feels each of his triumphs but
also really trudges through all of his
low moments like notice miles hands when
he talks to his mom no one my age says
those words in that order
yeah it's really hard to notice miles
jolts his hands just a tiny bit of
frustration to emphasize his point as he
wants to be left alone but he's also
hiding this from his mom because he
doesn't actually want her to leave
either it's a small human gesture and an
animator made this and by the way miles
can hear her being quiet because see a
spider sense but what he's really saying
is deep down he appreciates his mom
reaching out to him in this moment now
miles is New York as he looks out from
Brooklyn is larger than real life New
York but notice the Empire State
Building it's far from the tallest
skyscraper and one building right in the
middle has a neon sign for no surprise
Sony I also like how most buildings are
translucent but some are just empty
Border Lines like in video games the
comic books distant Horizons are often
not filled in all the way Rio observes
how miles is aged and the animators did
design the character to have hit a
growth spurt he's way lankier now than
we last saw him and by the way this chat
between Rio and miles is part of Miles
leaving that cookout that we see in the
other part of the trailer because leader
in the trailer you can see that party
behind her then we flash back to Miles
and various memorable shots from the
2018 into the spider-verse film but then
some new shots of Miles doing some
heroics in a Puerto Rican a neighborhood
there's a video screen with a character
who does look kind of like Jason
Schwartzman Jason Schwartzman is playing
the villain the spot Dr Jonathan own
miles swoops down to snatch a guy's hot
dog the action word take popping it up
for a frame but miles webs a 25 Bill
since remember Universe 1610 has some
alternate World details in it and it
sticks to a shirt with dollar signs and
a cent sign then we see miles leaving
the cookout worrying that Brooklyn
jersey number 42 of course that's what
his spider was numbered in the first
film and a reference to Jackie
Robinson's number on the Brooklyn
Dodgers Robinson of course played by
Chadwick Boseman in the film 42. now
among the stuff floating around miles
room which just did a great job breaking
down there's also a few Teriyaki mon
cards such as this universe Pokemon
cards we also know from last year's
teaser that there is a wooden moose
somewhere in this room an Easter egg
from the Lord and Miller film Mitchells
versus machines now again these portal
rings are hexagonal which in the MC it
was a recurring shape like the UNT and
wormholes and Wanda's hex and
wandervision but I wonder if each portal
could be a distinct universe that Miles
could off-ramp into as he goes to this
bridge like notice how miles passes
through each one he lights up into a
different color tone now this trippy
background looks like like glowing webs
that have been splattered and paint as
it was before but now it has its Bridge
suggesting that this is Miguel O'Hara's
architecture that he built to navigate
all of this chaos Gwen Stacy has now
been given her green Chuck Taylors from
the comics which Lord Miller revealed in
the after party video were actually
borrowed from Hobie brown spider Punk
voiced by Daniel colya in this film a
punk musician from Camden now Lord and
Miller described this area as a college
that's run by Miguel O'Hara that Gwen
has joined but miles is excluded from
for some reason it's sort of like the
older girl that goes off to college a
year earlier and the and the kid who's
like ah maybe I'll come up and visit you
in college sometime and you're like ah
okay maybe not yeah I got a lot going on
but but basically you get invited into
Oscar Isaac's cool spider Force yeah
into like the spider society and
um and Miles doesn't and you sort of
can't tell him why we see miles and
going together in this massive 3D
structure that is filled with Spider-Man
cameos again which just broke down but a
few animation details that I love here
there's a Spider-Man with a mechanical
Waldo arms and pilot headgear with his
arms hold a laptop that show him the
news as he sips his coffee and yes there
is a Spider-Man policeman who's
directing all this foot traffic
meanwhile miles and Gwen are in this lab
with some horrifying as Spider-Man
remains suspended from the ceiling and
Peter B Parker joins them and notice he
is wearing a baby born Lord of Miller
revealed that Peter B had a kid with
Mary Jane named Mayday who's gonna be in
this movie it's gonna be a bundle of
chaos with spider blood in her then this
great shot of miles of wind sitting
beside each other hanging upside down
wins ponytail hanging upward her hoodie
bunching up around her head and Gwen
leans her shoulder against miles's you
know that friendly thing that girls out
of your league do that they don't
realize makes their hearts explode miles
sequence relationship with this movie is
bringing me right back to that feeling
of being an awkward teen with a massive
Crush all of a sudden I'm worried about
my skin my hair and the way I smell all
things that can be easily improved with
a quick trip to geology.com geology is a
15 time award-winning personalized
skincare company recognized in hypebeast
birdie Men's Health Esquire and that's
been grooming Awards with over 6 000 5
Star reviews and they've recently
expanded to offer products for pretty
much whatever you need all you got to do
is take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology figures out your
routine for you like if you need some
hair care just use geology's co-wash
especially formulated cream cleanser
that removes the buildup and cleanses
the hair without the big lather or harsh
ingredients of the typical shampoo you
could find for the rest of your shower
routine you can use their body washes
they're free of harsh ingredients they
smell great and are refillable and for
after the shower protect your skin from
environmental stressors with vitamin C
plus e for Relic serum to keep your skin
looking young and healthy and then a bit
of dermatologist tested aluminum free
deodorant that honestly smells pretty
great and right now for a limited time
geology is hooking our audience up with
an absolutely insane offer if you use
the code new rockstars they will give
you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skin care trial set that
discount applies whether you're stocking
up for yourself or stuffing someone
else's stock instead either way geology
has you covered check out their awesome
gift sets featuring all of your favorite
geology products to get started just
click the link in the description take
their 30 second diagnostic quiz and
their team of Dermatology design a
personalized routine just for you that
ships directly to your door and then
from out of another hexagonal portal is
Jessica Drew Spider Woman boy spite
israe I love how we see a series of five
pastel outlines of her on her bike and
Jessica has webbing that shoots out of
each of her five fingertips the artist
maintained her yellow black and red
color scheme with red boots and a red
jacket red headband but yellow
sunglasses and a yellow zipper she looks
so great now she's fighting a version of
the vulture voiced by Jorma tacon who
void screen Goblin in the 2018 film now
his design is a sepia colored sketch he
actually model him on the drawings of
Leonardo da Vinci this vulture is going
to have an Italian accent coming from
Renaissance Era Florence as Jessica Drew
grinds him with a motorcycle tire notice
how tan feathers molt off of him then we
see Miguel O'Hara Spider-Man 2099 from
the post-credits scene of the 2018 film
he's reviewing an audio file of him with
his daughter this file is labeled
Gabriella 11 uh oh dead kid then miles
flees dozens of other spider folks like
a high school kid who snuck into the
Frat party as he moves a few frames show
his legs and His Hands fanned out all
together in one frame which is more
Looney Tunes scramble style animation
like what we saw from spider ham just a
really fun way of making miles look
desperate and clumsy there's a jock
Spider-Man whose leg smile slides under
and then another with a Santa hoodie and
Miles hand looks like it gets a little
too close to her booty and yes just
pointed out how in the upper left corner
is a literal spider monkey and I adore
this now Miguel Sprints toward miles as
miles looks trapped in an apparatus with
robotic arms either poking at him or
maybe cocooning him like could the
reason miles is being excluded is that
in Miguel's view miles becoming a
Spider-Man was an anomaly that wasn't
supposed to happen in Miles existence is
the root cause of the spider-verse
crisis so Miles thinks miles just needs
to be cocooned to patch the Flop it just
sounds like based on the audio here that
Miguel is going to be in antagonist to
miles so this could actually endear
miles closer to someone like the spot I
actually believe Jason Schwartzman was
cast in this role because of his roles
in movies like Rushmore Scott Pilgrim Vs
the World where he plays these nerdy
figures who don't really fit in and end
up bending the world to their will
director Kent Powers explained last
summer that the spot's design is meant
to look like an unfinished sketch
starting with blue construction lines to
look like a comic book artist rough
sketch before the anchor gets there and
that the character's design will evolve
over the course of the film as the
character becomes more and more
confident in his powers and as miles
flees upward from the others One Design
detail that I just love about the
bombastic Bag Man running beneath him
his ink dot inner texturing these are
the CMYK colors that were in every old
school comic book printing if you look
really closely but here notice that the
ink dots within him stay the same size
rather than reducing or enlarging to
convey distance like as he gets closer
it's just more dots which is wild
because it kind of suggests that
whatever the spatial distance is with
this guy he's just like cut out of an
ink universe that overlaps our own at a
constantly equidistant scale from us if
that didn't make any sense to you just
to play it back and watch it again and I
love it miles is able to foil the
bombastic back man by turning the paper
bag around on his head then Gwen appears
in close-up glowing vibrant yellow
Shades as robotic arms in that yellow
and blue diamond pattern forms behind
her seems like she is on the inside of
that cocoon structure that we saw miles
inside of earlier also it looks like she
has some artist initials on her cheek
maybe it's just a scar but it could be
like how Matt granion hit his initials
and Homer Simpson's hair in his ear then
Miguel gallops down what looks like some
kind of long vehicle along a futuristic
Nueva York Transportation line with
Spanish signs por favor limit please
follow the speed limit also a quick
frame shows miguela as part of an
animation storyboard with some artists
notes in the corner Imperial Violet and
crimson red this is instructing the
anchor what ink color to fill in the
character and these shades are these
specific shades of red and indigo for
Miguel's suit although there are a few
other characters behind Miguel here it
looks like Gwen and Peter B Parker
Miguel passes an ad mirinda Co I love
this detail because mirinda is a Spanish
soft drink that's now owned by PepsiCo
so I guess in Nuevo York Miranda bought
Pepsi instead and as Miguel grabs miles
they pass another ad for nuevasoft which
might be a variant of Microsoft now in
total there will be six new universes
shown here including Nueva York which
Lord Miller showed some Biz Dev art for
saying it was based on 70s and 80s
Sidney made drawings of an aspirational
future with an unfinished look in which
you can see the lines beneath it which
might explain the storyboard frame with
artist notes that we saw with Miguel
O'Hara they also revealed pavator
pravicar an Indian Spider-Man who lives
in mumbatin Marvel 50101 which we saw a
lot of in the first teaser that were
released in December 2021 be sure to go
watch that breakdown because all the
action words translate into like Hindi
and Tamil but Lord Miller said that
moment is the opposite of Manhattan in
that rather than going up and up it goes
down and down we're also going to see
Gwen Stacy's New York Universe 65 in
which Lord Miller said they based on
watercolor that changes based on Gwen's
mood oh my God the Artistry and the
design is what I love most about these
films it brings in a whole deeper layer
of meaning but definitely definitely go
watch Jess's Easter egg breakdown
because that woman spent so much time
identifying all the cameos to a death
that everyone else I've seen online is
giving up on and coming back up for air
but not Jessica she's brilliant she
found everything also stay tuned for
mt's awesome Multiverse logic breakdown
because the rules of the spider-verse
need some explaining and mt's got you
covered there you can follow me on Tick
Tock Hive Instagram and Twitter at hey
boss let me rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]